Come on, Arthur.
This is our time.
♪ I feel glorious, glorious ♪
- We all know. Anything
can happen out there.
Sometimes we feel lost.
We push and we suffer.
We keep going. That
makes all the difference.
Hey, what happened to you, boy?
You don't look so good.
Meatball?
Look, somebody likes
my meatballs.
- Hey, Paw Patrol.
We got a race to win.
- Just remember, Michael,
this race doesn't define you.
- I raced for 19 years. This
is my last chance to win.
- 3, 2, 1.
♪ I was a young
boy living in the city ♪
♪ All we do is
run, run, run, run, run ♪
- Over the next 10 days,
these athletes
will cross 400 miles
climbing, biking, and kayaking.
- That dot is Daddy.
- Go, Daddy dot.
- That's the dog I gave
the meatballs to.
Three days and 200 miles ago.
- Leave the stupid dog
and let's go. Come on.
Move, you dumb dog.
- What is it, boy?
- Oh.
- Oh, God.
- Can't believe I almost
walked right off that cliff.
Extra meatballs for you,
my friend.
He's hurting.
What do you think he went
through before he met us?
- Whatever it was,
it wasn't good.
- How the hell did he get
all the way from here to there?
While we were
on bikes and zip lines
and running and climbing?
- He must have wings.
We don't know about.
- Good boy.
♪ You know I'm back,
like I never left ♪
- You wanna start
to embrace the buckets of pain.
- I need a bigger bucket.
- Team Broadrail has
traveled over 200 miles,
and they've found a companion.
- Daddy has a dog.
- What have you done?
- Think you found a new partner
in suffering, Michael.
- Yeah, he's the king. I think
we should call him Arthur.
Arthur the King.
- How's he doing?
- He's been through so much.
- This dog needs a vet.
- I don't want you
to hurt anymore.
He's a fighter.
- Just like you.
♪ I feel glorious ♪
- Ah, the famous dog.
Looks even worse
than the rest of you.
Maybe you all
deserve each other.
- Always underestimated,
aren't we, buddy?
- This isn't the route
on the map.
- It's okay.
Just follow Arthur.
- Lead the way, King.
- I've never seen
anything like this.
- Everybody knows about him.
Guess what?
I'm not a dog person.
[dog whines]
♪ ♪